welcome to this video playing Alice per
week neck this is a frequent opponent
I've played them a number of times while
the Kings gambit let's let's try for
this counter gambit with f5 always leads
to fun stuff I'm not sure that this is
one of the really good lines really Wow
you maybe maybe you can do that by go h5
very very messy position he know of
course d5 don't want to give up if form
ok many interesting moves now even if
three azimuth yeah maybe
Bishop takes d4 maybe d4 by why now but
I have Knight takes d4 okay
okay so I'll take it I'll take it
um Knight takes d4 as my my threat
amongst others there should be seven
eyes and guests urges Bishop d7 what
Queenie seven habit Bishop e7 assistant
came the problem is that the g4 pawn
will fall and then also f5 will be gone
I don't say I don't think that yeah that
this is this can possibly work I can
just take it Queen takes there was
ninety four and T I can play Knight g4
Knight g4 Queenie for us the only move
that okay wait wait wait just for just a
moment
probably this is a position where one or
two precise moves were winning the game
Queen d4 maybe yeah Queen D form that's
good hard for him to not exchange now
now I'm just I'm just getting this as
well
threatening night f2 and threatening 96
yeah I came now Knight is six Luke in
one or just Bishop d6 56 son it's a good
square and still threaten to take
let's do a quick County I've got five
pawns and he's got what it's got seven
points at the moment so it's not it's
not like a complete no-brainer
the issues of course that I'm winning
stuff here
take care now or is there something but
I can also play Knight f3 yeah okay - I
just just take it and take it and also
have a bishop T - possibly
Knight f3 yeah it's all nice let's um
let's get the last pieces into play I'm
not sure if I have like a direct win
maybe I have but if I just get to get
the e6 pawn it's um it's simple
I'm just trying to play rook um yeah
just back here right
rook g1 this g5 just rook H to e8 and
take the e6 pawn it's my idea all night
f3 was also good yeah okay
sometimes just thinking for a moment
would help yeah I don't want Knight
Bishop to a5 so just play this
prophylactic move and then take next
should I play Knight f3 now
so it's a piece piece at the end and the
Jeep on
check-check
yeah rock h2 will push the Jeep on home
white resigned yeah the Sun this opening
line has claimed yet another victim it
was a bit strange all that I mean it's
it's usually strange to this opening I
think g4 is really not not good I mean I
mean this is the king I mean just just
not not on the computer wants to play a
play h6 actually here and then d5 which
is not bad
certainly computer wants to go g6 later
not a not a bad idea
this is also good though according to
the engine and III now is also strong
okay yeah it wants to play g4 now
d4 now sorry and this makes lots of
sense my idea was to take here Bishop g2
now complete complete crazy okay yeah
after that d4 think black is just
winning it's really no way to put it the
problem is it all falls apart yeah this
this this kingside scenario of him you
played 96 but let's say castles for
example I can take here Queen somewhere
and take here and then there is
absolutely no compensation when I get
the whole the whole King side basically
I mean I hope I'm a piece up yeah it's
not like he's got any I've got the
material and the compensation so the
same guy tiem there was all my multiple
ways to do it an idea three was the
easiest year I was just I had a head
prepare to plant this before and g5 it
just played it immediately but okay well
there's only one point to earn any game
ok thanks for watching